i'm emily compagno i'm guy benson i'm
shannon breme and this is the fox news
rundown
friday january 21st 2022 i'm chris
foster free coronavirus tests and masks
are going out as hundreds of thousands
probably millions of americans a day are
getting infected with coronavirus the
surge is peaked in much of the country i
think the beginning of the end is here
because we've achieved a high level of
vaccine immunity and you know everyone
who doesn't have good immunity and even
people who do are getting infected with
omicron we speak with admiral brett
jorah from former president trump's
coronavirus task force
i'm jessica rosenthal he's jesse waters
and his world will now be a nightly show
on fox news at 7 pm eastern time he says
he has a plan to tap into what he calls
a new grassroots movement of americans
who are over the existing power
structure we're kind of sick and tired
of being disrespected being lied to
being manipulated for money
being divided for political power
and i'm jimmy fella i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
the mind administration is having free
higher quality chronovirus face masks
distributed to pharmacies and health
centers and free coronavirus tests will
start arriving in people's mailboxes
over the next week or so more than 22
months into the coronavirus pandemic
should we have done more testing earlier
yes
but we're doing more now we've gone from
zero at home test a year ago to 375
million tests on the market in just this
month the president at his news
conference wednesday infections continue
to rise in more states than not although
many appear to be past their peak white
house spokeswoman jensaki tells fox you
heard the president say we don't want to
live like this forever we want to get
back to a point where we're not wearing
masks of course americans who want them
are eligible for five free n95 masks per
month from the government's strategic
national stockpile the free tests being
mailed to homes limited to four total
500 million tests over two to three
months it's really not enough to make a
significant impact so
um it's really a drop in the bucket
admiral brett jorah is former assistant
secretary for health and acting fda
commissioner also the coronavirus
testings are on former president trump's
chronovirus task force i think it's more
for
uh just the statement that he's doing it
more than having a public health impact
number two given the fact that we don't
have enough only 500 million over a few
months i really believe they should be
strategic about that in other words be
sending it to people who are at very
high risk of hospitalization or death
because remember we have oral
medications pills you can take by mouth
that if you test positive you can get on
those the earlier the better so i would
target them to high-risk individuals the
government knows who they are right
they're all in the medicare roles you
know who has comorbidities the final
thing is i really have problems with the
equity of this program because you get
four tests per household um
now
i really have concerns because i you
know i don't have the national data but
i do know that some of the highest risk
households have many more people than
just four people or two people or three
people it's the multi-generational
household that has the grandmother and
the great grandmother these are at very
very high risk
i mean if this was the brady bunch you
couldn't even test all the kids i mean i
don't know where they came up with
with four and there are another problem
i've heard that um there are people who
live in multi-family homes who share an
address technically and whoever
whichever family signs up first locks
the other one out there's also the issue
of
people who don't have a fixed address
who may need access to testing what
about the idea
of distributing the test the way they're
distributing the masks now where you
just
spread them out to every pharmacy in the
country and make them if not free highly
subsidized where if you need the test
you can go in and get them for a buck
yeah the problem is we don't have enough
and that's the issue
as as i see it uh divide the
administration
from january to september of 2021 really
didn't invest in testing
they invested in some infrastructure
around testing but they didn't guarantee
the market so that the manufacturing
lines the assembly lines all sort of
shut down and we saw the reports of even
major companies destroying their
home based test because there was no
market for it
they weren't doing that out of out of
spite you know the tests do have a shelf
life so you can't sell tests after
they're expired so now we're playing
catch-up we really are where we are now
we should have been here in march of
april of last year well something you
mentioned was part of the white house
defense of why you know why why now why
what took so long and they were like
look there wasn't a market for and i
guess omicron
is in their defense part of why people
are scrambling for tests now look we're
hearing numbers like 800 000 new
infections a day which speaks to how
contagious omicron may be but is that
number even relevant anymore i mean
nobody's keeping track of these at home
tests right how much are we under
accounting
um there are pretty good estimates about
how much we're under counting so the
real infections per day and this is by
multiple sources good mathematical
models that look at under counting in a
variety of the factors we're having
about six million new infections per day
in many states and that has been that
way for about a week they will probably
remain that way for about a week we have
certain states that are peaking and
coming down now about 20 states have
peaked and are starting to come down the
rest of the states are getting close to
that but yeah we're under counting
almost by a factor of 10. there are at
least 6 million new infections per day
so you're exactly right some of them are
home tests that don't get reported and
others are just mildly symptomatic or
asymptomatic infections that no one you
know they think they have a cold or the
sniffles or the sore throat so they
don't really go get tested so you know
nobody knows including themselves that
they have coded but it's a lot number
omicron is very very contagious as we
all know even to those who have been
doubly or triple vaccinated yeah i mean
all those infections of course can lead
to more and more infections so i guess
the the case rate is relevant in that
sense but otherwise we really probably
should be looking at hospitalizations
and deaths of course right if we're
talking about of course what kind of
public policy we should be putting in
place yeah of course because
hospitalizations and deaths are really
what we're trying to avoid you know
everyone in the country got the sniffles
for three days and nobody got
hospitalized or or died we wouldn't be
worried about this right it's it would
be a normal sort of cold season but what
we're really concerned about is in this
last wave of omicron is although omicron
is much less serious than delta or even
the previous experience or even the
native lung strain much less serious we
have so many infections
that
that the rate even though it's lower
hospitalizations the actual number of
hospitalizations are going up and
unfortunately
we know that mortality
lags so even at the peak of infections
go down a little bit over the next
couple of weeks and i think they
probably will
our mortality will probably remain high
for several weeks which which is you
know just an awful tragedy yeah i mean
even if it's pulling these numbers you
know out of nowhere but if if omicron is
half as virulent but five times as
contagious you're obviously going to end
up with more hospitalizations and more
deaths now look there are models and
there's a wide range that say we could
see anywhere from fifty thousand more to
three hundred thousand more american
deaths by the middle of march does that
sound reasonable to you do you think
we'll hit a million american copa deaths
it's 850 something now oh we'll hit a
million code to death uh unfortunately i
i think we're i think we're going to do
that it's just a matter of when you know
i am very hopeful predicting the future
is very difficult and this virus has
proven uh an incredible adversary
because of its you know a tendency to
evolve into some degree of aid immunity
i am hopeful that omicron between
omicron and vaccinations that we're
going to have a large degree of
population immunity and we're going to
see this go endemic at a at a much lower
rate and in much lower hospitalizations
yeah i mean one of the criticisms from
people about the vaccines is oh well
look look you've
they're still getting infected
um look at all these breakthrough
infections and you hear boosted people
being
infected once or twice more now but you
are trying to i guess you would
reiterate the fact that you do get
protection from serious illness and
death by being vastly boosted
yeah absolutely you have good protection
against serious illness and death from
omicron even with just two doses of
vaccine or a previous infection but you
can raise that protection dramatically
by getting a boost so a boost will raise
your protection against hospitalization
and death
another criticism of
this administration and the one you are
a part of is is the mass guidance it's
changed over time first you don't need
them don't worry about it and then okay
cloth is fine now people are strongly
urged to use n95 masks or the equivalent
i mean the defense there
from scientists is that well the virus
what we know about the virus is changing
but the cdc is still accused you know
from 2020 to now of muddled messaging
how would you have suggested
improvements there even if it's in
hindsight well i think the messaging was
certainly muddled i i do believe the
advice way back in in march
in 2020 in the trump administration
when you know particularly dr fauci said
don't wear masks are not helpful that
really wasn't the case we didn't know
whether they were helpful or not um
there was a shortage of them and i think
you should be straight with the american
people just saying look we don't know if
they're helpful or not but we have to
preserve them for the healthcare workers
i think that should have been the
message so i think it was muddled then
um in all fairness until omicron
wearing a mask provides some protection
right even the cloth mask and we know
that it was not perfect maybe 25 or 50
but there's no silver bullet it helps by
layering protection
when omicron hits
and and i want people to understand uh
it's a fundamentally different disease
you know it's still coveted and still a
variant but it is highly respiratory
transmitted in very small particles
which is one reason why you see the
number of cases so for omicron it seems
pretty clear that the certainly the
single layer cloth masks are not very
effective if you want to protect
yourself and others you need to wear a
well-fitting mask and that's preferably
a surgical mask or an n95 or km95 you
know that is you know omicron is
different
you know it's not because we messed up
the science or we didn't have the
messaging but people have to understand
that omicron is a different beast
compared even to delta
at what point other than maybe some hot
spots here in the country at what point
are we living with no restrictions going
back to late 2019.
you know there's not an on or off switch
right there really isn't but you know
we're going to see this gradually
transition and i think the beginning of
the end is here
because we've achieved a high level of
vaccine immunity and you know everyone
who doesn't have good immunity and even
people who do are getting infected with
omicron and omicron does provide a
strong natural boost to your immune
system
you know we're in the midst of a very
bad outbreak now but i i can tell you
that uh in many parts of the country you
know mobility is not down very much you
know i uh you know i go to the grocery
store i go to college basketball games
uh you know i i think you know for
people who've been vaccinated with that
previous coven uh the risk of of omicron
is is very low you know if i were 85
years old or i had cancer or i had
multiple sclerosis or some other you
know comorbid condition if my bmi was 45
i think i'd be really concerned
and i think those people are going to
have to be concerned into the future but
for the great majority of relatively
healthy people who've been vaccinated or
who have had cobia or preferably even if
you had covet getting vaccinated then
you're sort of super immune you know i
think we could go back to the relatively
normal society
former assistant health and human
service secretary admiral brett who are
also a medical doctor he was uh the
chronovirus testing czar in the trump
administration once the pandemic got
started admiral gerard thank you very
much for talking to us
really appreciate it
[Music]
this is jimmy fella with your fox news
commentary coming up
for several months you've seen several
hosts fill the 7 pm eastern primetime
slot on the fox news channel some
well-known fox personalities and some
you may have gotten to know better who
may have been panel guests or
contributors prior
but the hour has a new permanent host
with an eponymous title jesse waters
prime time you may remember first seeing
jesse with his waters world man on the
street segments for years it gives kind
of power back to the people that's the
opposite of socialism is it really
you're putting me on
so you want to make the rich less rich
sure yeah equality
damn it who typed a question mark on the
teleprompter has a poor person ever
offered you a job
they have not waters ended up as a
co-host on the five which airs at 5 p.m
on fox news democratic governors want to
fight tooth and nail to regulate their
own gun laws their own state taxes the
way their coveted regulations are
they're he will remain on the five but
he's moving on from his saturday night
show waters world we talked with jesse
about what we can expect each night and
what he plans to bring to viewers that
is uniquely his my
brand
is my connection to the audience
how i establish that connection on the
factor
traveling the country mixing it up with
all kinds of people on the street
so i'm very tapped in to what the people
want who they are
and what makes their heartbeat so i'm
gonna keep that in mind for every single
show
why do the people need to know this
how are the people feeling emotionally
about what's going on in the country and
how can we
together
come together
and
move this country in a better direction
and so
the show will be unpredictable
and
we will be introducing new types of
segments
new guests you haven't seen before but
also establishing some consistency with
some of the guests that you'll see on a
regular basis that i have great
chemistry with
and
one day we could be doing something
about food the next day we could be
doing something about
nuclear submarines and the next day we
could be investigating kamala harris's
nighttime activities
you never know what you're going to get
on prime time and that's what i think
the people should expect expect the
unexpected but we're going to be keeping
it real as always
is that what you think
got you the slot i mean we've seen a lot
of different hosts for months in that
position and it was fun right you got to
see a variety of takes you got to see
people more in depth who you might have
seen as guests on the channel um
and
i'm just wondering what you think it was
about your magical self that got you
this lot
well i mean i could go on for hours i
don't know if we have all that time but
um
one of the things that and just not
talking about why i got this but one of
the things that
i do
and maybe could be unique is that um
i have a smile on my face and we cover
the news
uh accurately and honestly and with a
lot of passion but at the same time
we'll have some fun with it and
no one says the news has to be boring
uh you were definitely going to make
some of these segments dance and pop and
you'll love that and you'll get used to
that but i really think
um you know
i'm not going to
go out there and have it be a rage fest
and
it's not going to be boring uh it's
going to be fun it's going to be
uplifting informational
definitely going to learn something
every show but
it's gonna be we're gonna be positive
and uh we're gonna be going in the right
direction yeah i don't want to call it a
smirk and i don't want to call it a mona
lisa smile but it is sort of like
like i know when i see you you're not it
it makes me wonder
you know do do we take things too
seriously sometimes like is is that
smile your way of saying okay yeah we're
gonna talk about this but let's take the
outrage down a notch
well i don't get outraged a lot and when
i do you'll see that on the show and
that's when you know i mean it you know
i'll be i'll be
tearing people's faces off when i think
they deserve it but you know i'll calm
down and
listen we live in a great country life
is great for the american people
compared to the rest of the world
uh we have freedom we have a lot of
wealth here and a beautiful beautiful
country
so things might be tough now and they
are tough in terms of
gas prices and inflation and crime and i
get that and i'm in touch with that and
we're going to talk about that but
it's going to get better
and because it always gets better
and it's going to get better because
we're going to get out of this thing
by shooting straight and uh and making
it work and i know everybody's gonna do
that
their own way right like you got to
change the country you got to change
your heart first we'll change hearts and
minds on prime time i guarantee it
people who watch fox already probably
already have a feel for your brand and
your delivery i would think just not
from the saturday night show but the
five which is popular obviously in its
own right when you go out and about what
do you hear from people about you do you
get ever like an airing of grievances or
is it mostly fans or is it like a weird
stare where people are like where do i
know him from
all of the above
i get uh i go you know obviously i'm out
here in manhattan so it's it's a liberal
town but you'd be shocked to know how
many
conservatives live in manhattan how many
fox viewers are here
you know sometimes they'll come up to
you and whisper hey i really like your
show
um and other times it's waters you know
they love it and uh you know i went out
the other day and i shot a package which
you're gonna see the first night a
little man on the street just asking
people what they think of prime time
what kind of guests they want to see
what kind of news they want to see
covered and
the number one thing that people want me
to talk about was crime
and it was black white male female
transgender and literally everyone i
talked to
mentioned crime as something they think
is a huge issue that they want to see
discussed on the news
and you know just being able to get out
there in the street and and know people
and feel it touch the energy uh yeah i
think that gives me advantage uh that a
lot of people don't have and and people
know me like that they're they're
friendly
some not so friendly and you'll see that
also on the package on monday got some
screamers
but we like that we embrace the hate uh
on prime time uh because it just uh it's
humorous and it makes me stronger
that's good um
it is good isn't it it is good to make
it to let it make you stronger and not
get like down or defeated yeah i don't
know if there's a better word than good
but yeah it is good um i remember i was
uh out and about i'm an mos man on the
street gatherer myself
when i've gone out um it used to be you
know maybe at the end of the uh
interview you know outside the coffee
shop somebody would be like hey what's
this for who are you
and now
people are more suspicious i get that
question more like off the top like who
are you what do you work for what is
this for
do you people have become more savvy
news consumers what is that about
yeah i've noticed that too
you know it used to be and it still is
depending on where you go you know you
just people if they see a camera they'll
just come right up to you they don't
even care what the topic
is they don't even ask what the topic is
they just say let's go i want to be on
tv
and those are the people you want really
you want really honest people that don't
have any guard up but
no people are suspicious because they've
seen how deceptive
television can be and in print
journalism can be and you know the the
editing the way the words are twisted
the agenda
obviously everyone has an agenda um so
yeah you know and i think if i could
give people advice you know be cautious
when when journalists so-called
journalists approach you with a camera
and microphone because you're at their
mercy unless it's live
um and and so just be cautious except
when you see me don't be cautious just
run right up to me or when they see you
um jesse people as you know often blame
the media rightly or wrongly for like
how divided
things feel
um and i think everyone in this business
you know is participating or engaging
some in a bigger way than others to the
to the national discourse we all have
some responsibility in this business for
what we say and what we put out there
you kind of addressed this earlier but
what do you think of as your role in
this time because it does feel like an
important time right i guess history
will tell but we just we just went
through this pandemic a lot has happened
politically
how do you feel about your role and what
it is in the discourse the country's
been disrespected for many years uh from
when we let china into the wto we sent
all the factories elsewhere
to
the iraq war which was just a meat
grinder
afghanistan another meat grinder people
coming back lost limbs opioid crisis we
haven't even really
focused on that to you know people
pouring across the southern border
driving down wages to
you know the great recession to this
crazy pandemic
the russia hoax you know we've lost
a lot of trust and faith in
experts and our political leadership
and they've made no effort to regain
that trust uh if you question them
they'll censor you they'll call you a
conspiracy theorist
so this is where we are right now in the
country uh we're kind of sick and tired
of being disrespected of being lied to
being manipulated for money
being divided for political power the
race card you know they
play the class warfare game constantly
we're tired of it
and
you can feel a new grassroots movement
arising whether it's parents upset at
school boards over crt or school
closings you can
feel parents mad in the inner city uh
about you know the lack of action
on crime uh you know people
feel like their dollar's been destroyed
when they go fill up when the shelves
are empty
so we're going to tap into that because
we feel it
we feel the disrespect and people are
starting to regain their footing and
look at
the fbi
uh
media
the white house
differently than we used to
so they have to remember that they work
for us it's not the other way around
and we're going to start cleaning house
and and putting people in charge that
represent us and that are responsive to
what we want because that's what this
country's founded on and
that's going to be my mission on prime
time
to get us back to that place but uh you
know we're not going to be vicious we're
just going to be honest and hold people
accountable and try to tell the truth
every single night jessie finally i have
to ask about your mom um because i loved
on the 5 when you would share her texts
from time to time i think it's safe to
say she's more liberal than you are are
you going to share some of her thoughts
about your show or is mom kind of tired
of the spotlight well mom is gonna stay
on the five mom text is a five
property but what we're gonna do and i
think i'm i haven't told people this
before but you know my mom gets a lot of
action she gets to
text me whenever she wants to be in
touch with me we're going to let
everybody text me now so we're going to
set up a number where the country can
text me
not just my mom everybody in the country
can sound off
about the show about whatever they want
and we're going to have a conversation
we'll put some other texts or their
emails or wherever they communicate
up on the back half of the show
and
i'm we're going to be in touch with the
people and that's what this is about
jesse waters thank you so much for your
time thank you so much
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network in
these ever-changing times you can rely
on fox news for hourly updates for the
very latest news and information on your
time listen and download now at
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you get
your favorite podcasts rate and review
the fox news rundown on apple podcasts
or wherever you listen
it's time for your fox news commentary
jimmy fala
what's on your mind so a new study finds
that 1 in 20 people have contemplated
suicide because of politics what it
doesn't mention is that they were
watching the view at the time they
thought about it i kid but this study is
no joke researchers found that 40 of
americans find politics to be a major
source of stress in their life the vast
majority of them happen to be college
students this one blows me away because
when i was in college we weren't
concerned with running the country we
were concerned with running out of beer
which might explain my grades the study
shows that people are just as stressed
under joe biden as they were under
donald trump and here's why politicians
have always fought for power but these
days we spend way more time fighting
along with them because of social media
politics in this country have become a
super stressful team sport that has us
rooting for our party over our country
because of twitter and facebook yeah
that's the bad news we've all gone nuts
but the good news for all you stretch
strugglers is america's gonna be fine
because we've been through much more
divisive times than these no this ain't
the civil war where we're gonna settle
things by picking up guns we just need
to put down our phones be sure to listen
to fox across america with me jimmy
fella weekdays from noon to three on the
fox news app or foxacrossamerica.com
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
from the fox news podcast network
download and listen to tyrus and tim
every week fox nation host tyrus and fox
news contributor kat tim give their hot
takes explore weird headlines and share
amusing stories subscribe and listen now
by going to foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes